so it's crazy because I remember the
first time I met you was like 2017 you
came up to the station you remember you
freestyle over triumph it will take me
for us and at that time you were this
was like mozzie leaned out on a cloud
mozzie you say me I fell asleep on you
and if yeah he was like in another world
I was I was in a whole nother world man
during that whole time yeah and I
remember like you know he's like you
killed it but I remember I remember
talking to uh you know talking to Ghazi
like man this if this guy could get his
[ __ ] together like he's a star you know
and then what I thought was so dope man
was you were the first rapper to really
make it okay to like kick the cup you
started that you started to kick the cup
challenge for sure most definitely and I
feel like it was needed because like
that wasn't cool at that point in time
and it was like somebody somebody needed
to step out and be like yo man you know
so it's okay to kick this [ __ ] my year
they bang me upside my hair for their -
I remember they're they bash me upside
my head all type of people uh but I
wasn't mad at it based on I feel like it
benefited more then than anything it
benefit a lot of people I'm similar than
anything so I'm I wasn't mad at it man I
take I take the lid and this was prior
to like you know obviously a lot of
people are trying to get clean now
because a lot of people passed away you
know juice world when it wasn't bully
bull to kick the Cup this when it was
[ __ ] with you timeout kicked it cut me
and Samia you know they was tweaking on
me but I ain't mad at it like I said I
take the link and I'm saying me if
somebody could benefit off of it was
that still is that still something you
struggle with because I know that that's
you know recreationally it's around I
just said it in my song man uh you know
at least I don't promote it on the
ground it's my addiction though he said
I told the road I quit each I forgot I
got all the right equipment
Oh talked about I quit it's hard to kick
it though Lisa I don't promote it on the
ground it's my addiction of it numb the
pain that I'll be going through who are
you to judge I miss you Brenda
without you I've been secluded so now
yeah you know I had a little bar in my
song where you know I was admitted to
admitting to relapsing right and but
you're not glorifying it not but I'm
glorified man I'm painted is this is
something that somebody so these is my
real struggles this is what I deal with
these is my everyday struggles I'm a
real human being and I'm seeing me and I
go through things and I find methods and
ways to to numb it and you know this is
my battle he's one of the battles that
I'm saying me I'm in a ring with and I
got a face but I wouldn't advise nobody
I love nor nobody you love to indulge in
them type activities